j'ai promis qu'ils allaient commencer
mon switch en parlant de la mer et voilà
comme je suis un très bon fils je pense
que d'anecdotes qui la suivent le résume
très bien la pensée voilà éviter que je
développe aujourd'hui j'avais je crois
peut-être dix ou vingt ans j'étais à
l'école et bien comme un indice non moi
je me suis dit tiens je vais je vais
écrire un journal journalisme allez je
vais faire j'ai pris mon stylo que je
fais quatre pages je mets un titre de
rappel c'était la sortie de titanic à
l'époque tous que sur un petit papier
sur le monde l'entrée et le fait que ça
mousse fine que ça va être
extraordinaire
je fais une page 10 sport une page mode
voilà est très fière de mal de mon
oeuvre
je vais à présenter donc ma famille j'ai
regardé voilà je suis un gentil à super
saison mais maintenant ils atteindront
responsables commencent à bah oui si tu
en as envie qu'il est plein de gens qui
les lie si tu veux la plus ample un
exemplaire il va falloir trouver
quelqu'un pour que je lançais oui quand
je vais vous en d'énergie dans ses
batteries bilité fille belge mais qu'est
ce que je dis mais va demander aux
toiles a demandé m
ok mais s'ils disent non et la marque un
temps d'arrêt depuis une magnifique
si je crois marquera toute ma vie elle
manie le nom tu l'as déjà
donc tout ce que tu rex qu'en réalité
ces deux oui fort de cette découverte
je me rends avec ma mère dans sa voiture
au mcdonald's le plus proche
tant qu'il était l'entreprise pour voilà
qu allait pouvoir financer mon nom
provient de manière exponentielle et il
a dit je viens avec moi non non c'est
ton brevet c'est un journal très bien
chantre m 20 cents restaurants et des
concerts par les directeurs et je pense
qu'ils vont envoyer quelqu'un qui n'est
absolument pas d'idée dernière des
lectrices mais qui a dû trouver à des
martèlements saba elle s'est assise avec
moi et donc je suis allé donc si on a
déjà une maquette et j'ai dit ben sassi
a expliqué je peux me tenir bien mais
alors là c'est le classer les gros
titres là c'est la page des sports place
et là c'est la mort voilà derrière
regarder ça c'est votre encarts
publicitaires mais notre logo ici et
puis vous allez me donner une somme
d'argent donc moins elle absolument plus
ce qu'elle était et voilà grâce à ça je
vais pouvoir diffuser ce journal des
milliers de gens en scène par mes
camarades de classe maison de ma famille
à voile c'est pour moi j'étais c'était
c'était le cours de l'action et il m'a
dit que c'est super génial de moi votre
mail votre niveau et je vais au contact
dans une semaine très bien
hélas le sort justement le prendre dans
la voiture fier comme un pape dit à ma
mère tu vas voir c'est génial voilà
j'étais certain que j'allais conquérir
le monde comme ma mère les tirs de match
aller vente des billets du jour ont fêté
leur ai pas vendu un seul et qui m'ont
jamais rappelé et malgré les 10 ou 15
appels dans la semaine
donc ce jour là je n'ai pas gagné
beaucoup d'argent
par contre j'ai appris des leçons
je pense qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de
valeur ce que doivent eux gagner à
l'époque à savoir des choses que je
pense qu'on a commencé à ne plus faire
quand on a plus de 10 ans avaient toutes
ces choses qu'on avait l'habitude de
faire que vous êtes est très naturel et
puis petit à petit en devenant à duke
ont arrêté de faire et qui pourtant sont
des qualités absolument indispensable
quand on veut entreprendre alors dans le
menace en particulier mais quand je dis
entreprendre ça peut être n'importe quoi
ça peut être faire écrire un livre
ça peut être wen ça peut être lancer un
projet ça devait être une conférence ça
peut être soit ça peut être un peu de
tout ce qu'on veut basse alors qu'il
faut quand même croire en soi même quand
on crée avec 20 c'est pas facile mais la
société et les gens tournent ou continue
nous dire toute la journée ou qu'on est
trop petit trop grand trop vieux trop
jeunes qu'on n'a pas le réseau qu'on n'a
pas d'argent
et en fait c'est juste des excuses parce
que en vérité quand on a un vrai projet
la capacité à avoir les ressources est
plus important que les ressources en
éveil donc ça c'est des choses qu'on n'a
oublié quand on a grandi et qui sont
absolument décide quand on va faire
quelque chose
la deuxième chose c'est que avant l'été
très impatient c'est vrai on n'était pas
demandée le tient je veux faire un truc
je lance un projet à je vais peut-être
attendre que les enfants
grandi j'ai peut-être attendre d'avoir
payé l'assurance peut-être je serai à la
retraite quand j'aurai un peu plus de
temps quand je me sentirai mieux
physiquement c'est pas des choses qu'on
entendait on a été très impatient et le
meilleur moment pour faire des choses
s'étaient tout de suite et maintenant
donc
donc voilà et la dernière chose qu'on a
oublié un petit peu en bas sans ses deux
plus avoir peur on a toujours peur
d'échouer ou d'être ridicule quoi qu'en
face c'est vrai maintenant on se limite
nous mêmes qu'on s'y maintient et non
j'ai peut-être pas là c'est ça qu'est ce
que vont dire mes parents puisque dans
ma famille qu'est ce que vont dire les
gens jettent pas forcément les
compétences et ça c'est des choses qu'on
faisait absolument pas quand on avait
dix ans et qu'on avait juste envie que
son journal soit lue par les militants
donc voilà s'il doit y avoir un mot de
la fin du deuil qu'il faut essayer de se
reconnecter à ce genre d'attitude voit
ce genre de choses qu'on avait au début
et qui font qu'en fait quand on trouve
quelque chose dont on est extrêmement
passionnés auxquels on croit et on
investir son temps ses efforts son coeur
ses tripes
il faut se lancer il faut commencer avec
la première étape il faut faire les
choses même si on sait pas les faire il
faut être très impatient très en demande
et ils continuer jusqu'à ce qu'on ait
réussi parce que parce que c'est un
petit peu la seule chose qu'ils ont à la
fin je pense pas qu'à la fin de ta vie
les décisions qu'ils étaient en vie le
plus heureuse soit celle qui était
guidée par la rationalité pur ou le sens
commun mais je pense que c'est la
décision qu'a prise en te disant moi
c'était peut-être un peu fou c'était
peut-être complètement déconnecté de la
réalité mais je les fais c'est peut-être
le truc que je regarde le moindre mal
voilà merci beaucoup